[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview the first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making the headlines with the
columnist and broadcaster steve richards
and the belfast telegraph columnist
alison morris so let's see what's on the
front page of some of those pages for
you now well the eye reports that while
hospital admissions amongst patients
with covid have risen by 38 in the last
week instances of serious illness
amongst those with the omicron variant
remain lower
the mirror is also confident with the
headline new year new hope it says
there's a growing belief that omicron
will not swamp the nhs despite a surge
in cases
the telegraph hears that some nhs text
messages are telling people to isolate
for an incorrect number of days after
government guidance changed last week
the mail leads with experts calls for
self-isolation periods in england to be
cut further to just five days
that's also the top story for the times
scotland's uh the national carries
criticism of the conservative mp sir
jeffrey clifton brown for referring to
the devolved nations as principalities
whilst discussing covert restrictions
the guardian focuses on warnings that
2022 will be the year of the squeeze as
the cost of living soars
and according to the financial times
2021 was a blockbuster year for
companies across the world despite the
pandemic they collectively generated
funds of more than 12 trillion dollars
joining me tonight steve richards and
alison morris to take us through the
newspapers welcome to you both let's
start by having a look at the eye
and uh their headline there saying that
more people in hospital with omicron but
this variant less severe than perhaps
previously thought
is this all as it seems is this
completely good news alison
well they're saying the number of
hospital cases is increased by 38
and obviously that's quite alarming
because that's quite a huge increase at
the same time too remember a lot of
people who have fallen to omicron are
also those healthcare workers they're
the nurses the cleaners the porters the
doctors and therefore the health
services already understand because of
that but it does seem to be less serious
and i know i think i probably know more
people who have caught covered in the
last month than i have known since last
march but none of them apparently have
been very seriously ill most have
described like a you know a head cold
and we have to hope that that is how
this virus has mutated because it
doesn't seem that there's any other way
out other than if the vaccines aren't
proven to be effective against it and
the virus itself is mutated into a
weaker a weaker form you have to hope so
they're saying why the hospital numbers
have increased the number of people on
ventilators the number of seriously ill
people who are likely to lose their
lives is not increasing and that's
really important because it takes so
many hospital staff to occur for someone
who is in intensive care that is with
the sort of labor intensive aspect of
looking after patients with covert and
that is what puts the most stress on the
health service so we can only hope i
think that there's a delay in the number
between cases and the time of of serious
hospitalization so i don't think we're
quite out of the woods yet maybe the
middle of january we'll know for sure
but you know i've always tried to remain
optimistic in terms of this you have to
look at the sort of glass half full side
of it and if scientists and experts and
people who know much better than me are
saying that this variant may be weaker
and this may be our way out well then
you've only you know i'm going to take
what they've said and hope that hope
that that's accurate
but but though the symptoms might be
milder uh steve there are still
consequences because people are still
having to to isolate so still
consequences on how we live our lives
and also on the economy
yeah and uh as that headline indicated a
lot of people are still going into
hospital um though without the same
severe symptoms as with previous
variants so that kind of raises some
very interesting issues this
this covered saga at each junction there
are new questions arising and it seems
to me one of them now is that the
evidence suggests a lot of the people
who need hospital care with this mild
apparently mild variant haven't had the
vaccine
so how do we
learn to live with covid to use that
cliche
when there is this reluctance to get the
vaccine on quite a significant
proportion of the population it seems to
me that's the key question that arises
from this one
like allison virtually everyone i know
has got this variant
i'm about the only one who hasn't got it
uh of the people i know
um but it does seem to be if you've had
the triple vaccination much less severe
but if you haven't
some people get into hospital and that's
on top of people who've got the delta on
top of people who get flu at this time
of year
so there is still an increased pressure
on an nhs already creaking for all kinds
of different reasons not least two years
of this
and we've got to work out a way of
getting more people vaccinated meanwhile
the mirror saying the virus fight still
rages on but quite an optimistic
headline new year new hope and they're
quoting professor john bell who's saying
that that jabs have have helped and um
uh added to to the fight against um
omicron and he's saying that the
horrific scenes we saw a year ago a
history in his uh opinion
alison
yeah and and we have to hope that that's
because of the vaccine and that's why
we're in a different situation this
christmas than we were last christmas i
mean i had covered earlier on in the
year in october and i had a very mild
dose of it and i assumed that the
vaccine helped with that i was actually
able to work the from home albeit the
whole way through it and it was fine i
know people who had more serious
illnesses and i think that that's really
those people who were frontline workers
people like nurses and teachers who were
subjected to like you know massive viral
loads of the virus and we have to look
at how they can be better protected
going forward and but i mean
sir john bell you know is is a professor
he's someone who knows exactly what he's
talking about he's looked at the data
and he said that this may be finally the
path out of this i don't think that any
of his thought when this started last
march that would still be sitting here
talking about it but the problem is with
the fact that we have had you know
success of governments who have depleted
the nhs and so it was never ready for a
pandemic of this scale in northern
ireland our health service was
practically on its knees before covered
with atrocious waiting lists the worst
in the uk so imagine how much worse that
has been made by covenant by the fact
that we have so many nurses and doctors
and hospital staff now isolating and all
of those things should have been dealt
with in terms of future proof in the nhs
making sure it was properly funded and
making sure that the staff there were
properly paid and felt valued because
we've also seen hundreds of nhs nurses
specialists you know and icu nurses
leaving for other jobs because they just
felt underpaid and and at that point
they weren't being properly treated as
the way they should have been because
these are the people that we're relying
on to save our lives when something such
as this happens and steve despite the
optimistic tone of the the mirror and
the suggestion that the worst of the
pandemic may be over there's still a
warning that that those going out to
celebrate uh new year's should be
cautious
yeah and they're not necessarily saying
the worst pandemic
they're referring to this particular
variant at the
optimism that it's nowhere near as
severe as some of the others but clearly
there needs to be caution i mean
everyone is catching this thing um you
know meeting over a coffee so you can
imagine what it's going to be like on
new year's eve in nightclubs and pubs
and all the rest of it in england at
least where you know the sort of
libertarian streak of this government
has prevailed
and
you know as i say although it is less
severe the hospitalization numbers on
top of all the other pressures
could become considerable and it will be
those who haven't had the
vaccines so um yeah
it's great that it's nowhere near as
severe it seems as some of the others
but still with big implications for the
demands on the nhs
alison to the uh daily telegraph and
test and trace uh seemingly giving
misinformation to people regards to the
isolation period
yeah well the isolation period is
supposed to not be seven days if you
test negative which is the important
part of that um the telegraph is
reporting that it's still telling people
to isolate for 10 days which obviously
is putting strain on those front line
services and just tonight before i came
on here and my day job i was reporting
about how the police service of northern
ireland were operating with 20 percent
less officers over the christmas period
because so many of them are isolating
and that seems to be replicated across
the uk and also in the state of ireland
they're also struggling in terms of of
those numbers so getting that down to
the seven days of people test negative
is very important but also i do think
it's important to remember that it has
to be done in a safe way there is also a
push to try and go for the five days
which the us government have now
introduced and we have to make sure that
those five days aren't just about
keeping business going rather than
keeping people safe and that make sure
that there is enough tests available
that people test negative before they're
forced to go back to work again this is
a serious issue though isn't it because
it's causing unnecessary confusion steve
yeah although do you think many of that
confused i mean i think it's pretty
clear that the
uh well if they're getting messages
saying that it should be ten ten days
even though they might have seen
elsewhere that it's seven
i'll have to use the word phrase cock-up
and there'll be lots of cock-ups on
roone and clearly it will be a minor
temporary issue
um but it is clear i mean there's a
bigger debate about whether the
new time should be revised to be
less than it currently is but i think
that won't be a big issue for very long
let's take a look at the guardian now
and this is sobering for for all
consumers um it's going to get tighter
than it's already been cost of living
set to absolutely soar we know some of
this precipitated by the the energy uh
rises that are looking likely to come in
50 or more increase um it's not looking
great for 2022 with this prospect is it
alison
you know it's horrendous when you think
about what a 1
200 pound a year
increase in the cost of living does to
some families who already live in on the
red line here burley making ends meet
you know we've seen a massive increase
in the use of food banks and i think
that the link between you know what's
happening in terms of the increase in
fuel prices but also in terms of the
fact that wages and especially public
sector wages haven't increased along
with that means in real terms a lot of
people have had almost pay decreases um
when you look at the the cost of
inflation in terms of car prices have
been rising and it just puts some people
in such a dire situation where they're
having to choose whether they ate or
whether they hate their homes and it's
as simple as that you know some of us
are very lucky and we're in very
privileged positions but i always say
well i'm a woman of privilege now i
wasn't always i was once a teenage
mother i was once living on benefits i
was once living in a situation where my
budget was worked out down to the last
50 pence every week and if you'd put a
massive increase like that in terms of
the price of gas and the type and the
price of food i just wouldn't have been
able to budget my money and it's as
simple as that and there are people
living like that every day and these are
people who are working hard who are
doing you know really difficult jobs
really difficult hard frontline jobs in
many cases and they're just not being
paid enough to keep their families i
think that there needs to be urgent um
an urgent um intervention by government
to tackle this to ensure that employers
are paying a living wage and not just a
minimum wage and to give people who are
on those of people who are on the the
breadline people who are the working
poor people who are struck on on
benefits or in sickness benefits extra
help with hayton especially during the
next you know few months in those winter
months because otherwise i'm not sure
that many families will be able to cope
um and we know that we're talking about
hospitals and the pressure on hospitals
well poverty and health are completely
linked if you don't deal with one then
you see an increase in admissions to the
other one you know the two things are
work hand in hand uh the resolution
foundation uh the think tank which is um
giving some of these stats is describing
it as a cost of living catastrophe i
mean this is going to push very many
families over the edge isn't it steve
is the resolution foundation do well
with generating news stories out of its
very kind of forensic analysis of what's
going on it's on the front pages of
quite a few of tomorrow's papers not
just the guardian the interesting thing
about this is i mean it basically
highlights two elements a a big tax rise
coming up at the start of the next
financial year in april
and as uh alison was discussing the the
big increase in gas prices looming
um neither are inevitable uh the tax
rise
there was absolutely a an incredibly
powerful case to raise taxes to pay for
the demands on the nhs and social care
it didn't have to be done with the rise
in national insurance which is the way
it's going to happen and that will
affect a lot of people
and the gas market in britain is so
wacky all these companies betting in
effect gambling on the price of gas and
then incapable of coping
um when the the the sort of calculations
have gone all wrong with soaring costs
of the gas which they themselves don't
provide and so
that's just two examples i think i think
inflation will be fueled partly by those
rises but through other things like
there's gonna be much tighter brexit
controls on trade starting in january
and that will have an impact as well so
it's going to be a really challenging
time and what's interesting is whether
this does have an impact on the
government's standing which is already
behind in the polls at the moment for
all the other issues indeed steve and
alison we must leave it there